foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Rick Stroud covers the Buccaneers for
the Tampa Bay Times host of Sports day
Tampa Bay podcast
seems like a foregone conclusion Rick
Tom Brady's plan next year I guess the
question is Tampa or the field
yeah um can I take the State of Florida
can we can we take that and just say
sure one step because I I really do
believe that for as much talk as there
has been about San Francisco too far
right they got Brock Purdy they got
their quarterbacks Trey Lance Denver
same thing Las Vegas he now has three
kids that don't live with him full time
and they're in Florida two of them one's
in New York so I I still think Miami is
a possibility depending on what people
do down there with Tua uh maybe even
with the head coach
um you know and and I was told by
somebody pretty close to them that
and I would have never said this Dan in
fact I said the opposite shows what I
know that that he might come right back
here to Tampa he really really likes
working for the glazers he has a great
relationship with them they give him
everything he wants it's certainly still
in the state not far from uh you know
from where his ex-wife is so he might
want to fix this uh if that's possible
and I wouldn't discount the Bucks having
another crack at him are the Bucks
threatening
in the playoffs yeah
yeah
they are
um but only because of one guy and it's
also Dan because of the way I think
he'll play you know his whole year of
course was you know full of all kinds of
uh you know personal Strife but beyond
that
he really didn't want to get hit he
didn't want to uh you know he didn't
trust the offensive line he had to make
it through the regular season that was
the goal that was the whole goal of his
since he tore his ACL back in 08 and he
knew he had to be here for his team well
he played Carolina and they had to win
he sat back in the pocket and he threw
the ball down the field now they played
the name single coverage you know
against Mike Evans and they they bombed
away but I really think that in the
postseason we saw this last year with
the Rams he got hit 15 times nine times
by Von Miller but he stood in there and
he looked down the barrel and he threw
it why is he playing if not for the
postseason if not to try to get in the
Super Bowl and I think that's going to
open up their offense quite a bit plus
there's healthy as they've been I mean
Julio Jones who we haven't seen he's
been on the Shelf he's been quietly
working I think you're going to see a
lot of him and you know we'll just see
if they have problems on the offensive
line but those guys have played a lot of
football now and I think they feel they
have a little bit of confidence going
but what have you seen from the Cowboys
defense the last month they have not
looked good good at all including last
week against the commanders and how does
Tom Brady take advantage of that
well they got to protect them I mean
that's number one I mean for all that
the Cowboys have done and they gave up
what 500 yards to Jacksonville
um you know the Bucks unfortunately
they're the worst rushing team in the
league I mean historically bad under 80
yards a game I think only four teams
have made the playoffs with that low of
a rushing average but the biggest thing
is can you block Micah Parsons can you
keep Tom clean if they can do that
there's yards to be made you know we'll
see what kind of coverage they play but
there's going to be some man-to-man
opportunities and you know the first
game they ran the ball very well they
got it outside they got it on the edge
they made those guys run sideline to
Sidelines so I don't know that the game
plan will be different this time of year
he seems to trust Leonard fournette but
a big game in Arizona a couple weeks ago
so I think there is a way to attack them
but but you're right I mean look
America's this is America's team against
what uh Captain America right America's
quarterback and it's intriguing because
that's really the matchup and you got
Jerry Jones you know every year the
pressure bills on Dallas us I think
they're going to feel it I really
believe that the Cowboys are going to
win you know all that stuff and listen
um that's real you know and this team
for whatever reason has beaten this team
twice now in the season opener in two
years so they're confident it hasn't
been a good year it could go that way
again uh in this playoff game but I
think when you get to this part the
pressure is what all the teams feel and
who handles that best no one handles it
better than Tom Brady
Tampa I believe is two and four against
playoff teams this year
best team you saw this year that they
faced oh San Francisco by far yeah it
wasn't even close and with Brock Purdy
making his first start
um you know what's going to be
interesting about them and they're
terrific they have the defense they can
run the ball the Christian McCaffrey
deal was genius uh I want to see what
happens though if much like Jimmy
Garoppolo before him if the 49ers are in
a trail position in the fourth quarter
and Brock Purdy has to throw the ball
you know down the field in a clock
situation is he going to be able to
handle that
um and and we he just hasn't been in
that position yet so but no by far San
Francisco is the best team I've seen
yeah you start to look at these
situations I I pointed out in the first
few minutes of the show that we look at
these matchups we may not like the teams
the Giants and the Vikings but that
might turn out to be a great game the
Chargers in Jacksonville looking at the
the lion that should be a great game uh
you know you got Miami against Buffalo
not much of a chance there you got
Seattle against San Francisco not much
of a chance there the one game you think
that will take away from this weekend
talking about on Monday slash Tuesday is
what
uh wow that's a great question I I think
it's going to be the New York Giants
beating the Vikings I think we're going
to see a Giants team that
um has some pieces that can give teams
trouble they're physical they can run
the football Daniel Jones can be a
problem and I I just don't trust
Minnesota I don't know how you can trust
the team with that kind of Point
differential they're just up and down
and if that happens then you have a
situation where if the Bucks were to win
they'd be going to San Francisco it
could really throw sort of the playoffs
into a loop but um but yeah I'm really
interested in that Vikings Giants game
I'm trying to understand this quote from
Lamar Jackson I know that you cover more
than just the Buccaneers you covered the
NFL but he says yeah I wish I could be
out there with my guys more than
anything but I can't give 100 of myself
to my guys and fans I'm still hopeful we
still have a chance
what do you take from that
um well first of all nobody's a hundred
percent just go there first
um get out there if you can even if
you're 65 let's give it the old College
try
I still think we have a chance I mean
that that seems a little uh dark you
know you might want to get behind your
guys a little bit more than that
I don't know what Lamar Jackson's future
is I don't know do you hand a guy like
that the kind of contract he's going to
command uh if you think that this is
going to be a pattern if you think that
his style of play is going to put him In
Harm's Way over and over again it's it's
a difficult decision by the same token
who's out there right what what position
are you in to get another quarterback
um but you have to be available for your
team and and he's not and this has been
a you know an ongoing saga week to week
so
um I don't give you know the Ravens much
chance and and I don't know how this
impacts their feelings about Lamar going
forward I think they have to sign them
Dan but I but I'm not sure yeah I think
they're going to franchise him I mean I
would still take a wait and see coming
off this injury been injured the last
couple of years
and he's got to look at Deshawn Watson's
deal and say I want mine all guaranteed
and they weren't willing to guarantee
you know there was like 133 out of 250
million dollars uh I want to leave you
with this and I want to take you back to
last summer when we spoke and you knew
what was going on with Tom Brady and his
family situation but as a reporter being
respectful and also being in that market
with Tom Brady and seeing him on a
semi-regular basis
where do you
how do you kind of compartmentalize to
go I'm I've got to do my job but it's a
sensitive topic of somebody who's going
through a divorce but it is affecting a
football player and a football team and
a city that you live in
it's a great question and we wrestled
with it
um not that much though because again
um you know I I'm I work for a newspaper
and and now our digital company or
whatever they they call themselves now
um and it's journalism and you know even
celebrities like Tom Brady and Gisele
um deserve a certain amount of privacy
and furthermore
um we kind of Drew the line at is there
a document that says there's is there a
filing is there something on paper that
says this is actually happening we knew
kind of what The Strife was but it's you
know in any situation like this it's
totally fluid you don't want to be first
and wrong on this one you have to be
correct and you also have to respect the
process there's children involved and
again these kids you know were born into
this family and and they're in the
spotlight and commercials and everything
else but that's their mom that's their
dad and so
um you have to be very careful and
sensitive to that where we could see
what was going on with Tom he hinted it
some personal Strife you know during the
season about I got some bleep going on
and we saw the weight loss and all of
that
um and we knew that he took time away
for that reason but aside from
documenting those absences it was really
difficult to come out and say well this
this marriage is ending and I had
written stories and had them ready to go
in the event that you know that that was
proven but without a spokesperson for
one of those parties or without a
document that's kind of where we drew
the line and everybody else can answer
for themselves but I just think you have
to be respectful of uh of where the
situation is and of everybody involved
not not just not just Giselle and Tom
yeah I wrestled with that as well but I
kept going back to how I covered Tiger
Woods when all of this came out about
what was happening with other women I
only care what happens to you the golfer
the the performer if it took him off the
golf course if he didn't play in Majors
or Tom missed practice Tom did miss
practice then you know when I found out
eventually then I went he's missing
practice now it's a story but prior to
that I I couldn't I couldn't do TMZ I
couldn't broach the topic
yeah and I think that's fair I think
when you uh see that it's affecting him
on the field and obviously this is the
most prepared quarterback of all time
still might be if you just rolled out of
bed and played but he wasn't preparing
the way he normally prepares and I think
it had an effect on his play I mean you
know he didn't have the chemistry he
talked about you know not getting enough
reps with some of his guys and I think
that early on that that was that was a
story just just you know look after the
Ravens game Dan he sat there and no one
had ever seen this we talked to people
in New England but for a good 20-25
minutes in full pads with his head
between his legs um at his locker and
Blaine Gabbert was talking to him he had
no response the next day the divorce was
Final the next day they filed and they
filed the final papers and so they had
lost two games in four days they were
three and five and boy you can see uh
you know how the weight of that had
affected him on and and was affecting
him you know off the field but on the
field as well so we wrote about that
scene um but that's really all we could
do you know I I just think that you can
write about how whatever it is he's
going through and wants to share his
effective on the field but without uh
you know one of them acknowledging it I
just didn't feel comfortable writing
that that was happening always great to
talk to you Rick thanks for joining us
thanks Dan that's Rick Stroud covers the
Buccaneers for the Tampa Bay Times host
of Sports day Tampa Bay